[MUSIC PLAYING]
Good evening.
Welcome to the second lecture
of the College of Science.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm not sure how many
of you are repeats.
But I got dressed up for you.
[LAUGHTER]
I want to thank the underwriters
of this lecture series.
Again, let me just mention their
names because it is important
that we all recognize
that they're
supporting all of
us being in here,
watching these great lectures,
the Arizona Center on Aging,
"Arizona Daily Star," Cox
Communications, Galileo Circle,
Godat Design, Bob Davis of
Innovation Park, Raytheon,
Research Corporation, Sanofi
US, The Marshall Foundation,
UniSource Energy, and
Ventana Medical Systems.
Please help me thank them.
[APPLAUSE]
And before I introduce
the speaker tonight,
I was coming down the road.
And they were
interviewing Woody Allen
because he has a new movie.
And they were interviewing him.
And all of you remember
that all of his movies
are full of angst, and
death, and worries.
So they asked him what
he thought about death?
And he says, I'm
still against it.
[LAUGHTER]
That's pretty-- But today,
it's not about that at all.
It's not about
against it or not.
It's how to get
there gracefully.
Now, let me introduce then
our speaker, who's going
to be telling us about that.
Janko Nikolich-Zugich is a noted
expert on the immune system
and age-related disorders.
He's a department head of
immunology and co-director
of the Arizona Center on Aging
at the University of Arizona,
where he leads the biology
of aging research program,
collaborating with others to
address diseases and conditions
such as obesity,
inflammation, osteoporosis,
infectious diseases, diabetes,
cancer, and dementias.
Originally from Belgrade, Janko
received his medical master's
and doctoral degrees from
Belgrade University Medical
School.
He did his post-doctoral
training at the Scripps Clinic
and Research Foundation
and started his career
at the Memorial Sloan-Kettering
Cancer Center and the Cornell
University Medical College.
Before joining the
UofA, Janko was
professor at the
School of Medicine
at Oregon Health
Sciences University,
where he realized that our
basketball team, as well as
our medical school, was better.
[LAUGHTER]
And he was a senior scientist
of the OHSU Vaccine and Gene
Therapy Institute.
Please help me welcome
our distinguished speaker.
[APPLAUSE]
So thank you Joaquin for
a wonderful introduction.
And thank you all for coming.
And I would first like
to thank our sponsors who
make this possible.
And without you, of
course, we couldn't
do that, and particularly
the Galileo Circle.
So we're going to talk about
some fun things tonight.
And I would first like
to thank more people that
made my specific
presentation possible.
So in no particular order
here, but with all of them
being really close to
my heart and really
being very helpful
in this case, I
would first like to acknowledge
Mindy Fain, my co-director
in the Center on Aging
and a great collaborator
and colleague, who
helped me formulate
some of the ideas
for the presentation.
Ken and Carl did a wonderful
job at putting some of the ideas
into wonderful graphics.
Jen Uhrlaub, who's my
laboratory manager,
also provided a bunch of photos.
My entire lab, great
to have you guys.
Many of you are here.
And then very much
major, major thanks
to Rich Miller, a prominent
gerontologist at the University
of Michigan, who provided
me with a number of slides,
as well as ideas for
the presentation.
And finally, and
certainly last, but not
least, my incredible
family, my great wife
Dragana-- thank you, honey--
and my children, Tijana, Mina,
and Stefan.
And I have to acknowledge
also our funders, the National
Institute on Aging and
other NIH Institutes,
as well as the SENS Found, the
Bowman Trust, and the Hudson
Family Trust.
So really, the real
title of today's talk
is "Why Do Our Bodies Grow Old?"
But more importantly,
what can we do about it?
So I would like to start it
with a question to all of you.
You have two choices.
You can pick to have a
slow and gradual decay,
or decline actually,
in function.
Not decay, we hate that word.
It somehow gets into our
vocabulary from physics.
And we really don't like it.
Decline in function
over time as you age.
Or you could have it be very
sudden and precipitous, meaning
that it's maintained
for a long time.
And then it kind of,
like, just crashes down.
So I'd like to see a
show of hands here.
How many would like the
first part, long and slow?
[LAUGHTER]
And how many would like the
maintain and then crash?
Awesome!
Because that's really what
we're going to be talking about.
So I would like to
make two points really.
The first one is that I
will give you a promise.
And the promise is not from me.
It's really from the
biology of aging science.
And that is that we can
change the face of aging.
And the idea would be to
get most people to live
to be about 112 years old.
But more importantly, to be
healthy for the first 111
years of that.
[APPLAUSE]
And second is that if
we already do that,
we really can't do
business as usual.
We can't think the way that
we have been thinking so far.
We really have to
invest in the prevention
of age-related disability
in the whole body and mind.
We can't be really attacking
this whole story one disease
after another.
It doesn't work.
And I'll tell you why.
So what are we trying to do?
When we say that we want to
change the face of aging,
what are we looking for?
Well, we're not looking
to abrogate aging.
We're not looking
to erase aging.
to eradicate it.
We're not looking to
prolong the suffering.
If we gain another three
decades of life or more,
we really don't want
them to be miserable.
We want him to be vibrant.
We want them to be vital
and the quality of life
is supposed to be high.
So here you're
seeing the projection
of how currently the
function, the quality of life,
declines over time.
And this is what we're
really looking to do.
So we are really trying to get
to this vigorous and vibrant
life span and compress
disability as we go along.
And I'll tell you the
reasons why I think
this is completely possible.
So when we talk about
quality of life,
we talk about different things.
And so these are some of
the important components
of the quality of life.
This is really the
health-related quality of life.
But it contains components
of social activities,
and interpersonal relationships,
and sexuality, mental health,
and satisfaction with care,
a lot of other things.
But when you think
about aging in terms
of how it impacts our
tissues, and our bodies,
and our cells, most
people when they
think about functional aging,
envision this kind of a line.
So there is a decline over time.
As the years go by,
the functions go down.
And that is, of course,
correct in part.
But the part that gets
lost really too often
is the other line.
And that other line goes
in the other direction.
And that line talks really about
experience, and about wisdom,
and about everything
that people accumulate
as they grow old, which is
very good and very important.
And so I would like to ask you
to think about older adults,
first and foremost, as
a societal resource.
And as we go along, I
would like to tell you more
about the biology of aging.
So the biology of aging
deals with these fundamental
processes as they go
along in our bodies.
And so when you think
about how we are conceived,
we start from
really a tiny cell.
And this process of development
is very highly ordered, very
highly structured.
It basically takes that cell
through an intermediate stage
of these children, to come to
something that looks like this.
If they're not really a
fully mature adult form,
they're getting close to that.
And it's a highly
ordered process.
If something goes wrong, there
is a terrible price to pay.
The genes are all
precisely orchestrated.
They do things in concert.
And all of that is
very, very precise.
Unlike that, aging
is really what
happens when the rules weaken
and sometimes even expire.
So the processes are no longer
quite as tightly correlated.
It's not a symphony anymore.
There is a little bit of this
instrument or that instrument,
kind of like being a
little bit out of tune.
Why do we age at all, in fact?
So the reason is that
we have some genes that
do great things early.
But they can do
bad things later.
So genes that are involved in
proliferation and cell division
are really important
when we grow.
But as we grow older,
they are the ones that
very often can give us cancer.
There are other genes that
don't do great things.
But we control them very well.
And sometimes they get out
of check as we grow older.
So what are then
the basic questions
about the aging process?
Well, the first one
is, is there a plan?
Is there a master
plan for aging?
And the answer is
probably there isn't.
And guys, I'm going to
give you a sneak preview
into the answers as we go along.
The second question
is, is there a clock
that allows this to run and
then start at a given time?
And I think the answer is
that maybe there is a clock?
What is the clock,
we can discuss later.
And finally, the question
is how does aging
produce signs and
symptoms of aging,
that which we
recognize as being old?
And so we'll go
through these questions
and try to understand them.
But I would like
to first give you
a couple of important
and key facts.
So most organisms age in
a very similar manner.
And if you only look at
mammals, for instance,
they all age in a
very similar manner.
The difference is that they
take different times to age.
So some take 70 years.
Some take about
two to three years.
And that differential
is about 30-fold.
So it's quite amazing.
So understanding
why that happens
at certain rates
in certain species
is quite important in
order to understand aging.
Well, the other and
the more important fact
here is that there
is this intervention
that you heard Shane Burgess
mention in the last lecture.
It's called caloric restriction.
It's really a 33% reduction
in calorie intake.
You don't stop eating
anything else less,
other than the calories.
So your vitamins are 100%.
Your minerals are 100%.
It's the net calories that
are reduced by about a third.
And as a consequence,
this intervention
has been shown more
than 80 years ago now,
to produce a 40% extension
in the lifespan in laboratory
animals of different kinds.
What's more important
is that these animals
are really healthy.
They run a lot, as
you have seen here.
And more importantly, they
run a lot, almost three miles
a day, at a time where
most of their littermates
that have been kept on an
ordinary diet are long dead.
They are devoid of most
of the signs of aging,
most of the diseases of aging.
They don't get nearly
as many cancers.
Their cardiovascular
system looks great.
They've got a great heart, great
arteries, and so on, and so on.
And the other important
point is that there
is at least 10 different
gene mutants that
also live extended lifespans.
And that are also blessed
with increased quality
of life at the same time.
And those are all
probably working
through the same
basic mechanism.
So what does that really mean?
Well, it means pure magic.
I mean in science,
if you're really
trying to discover
something, and you
discover something like
this-- and, of course,
I didn't discover this.
I mean there's been people,
many, many generations
before me.
And my generation of scientists
have gotten the first insight
into this.
This is the wow moment.
This is the intervention that
does universally this fantastic
thing.
And it does it throughout
the animal kingdom.
So one simple intervention
and the same genes that lie
downstream of that.
Particularly, the
insulin genes that
regulate the insulin pathway.
Which is really the pathway
that kind of, like, tells you,
did you eat enough?
Did you not eat enough?
Are you supposed to
recycle yourself?
Are you supposed
to go and divide?
How do you regulate
all of these things?
So all of these genes, the
insulin growth receptor
pathway, control the
aging and function
in the same manner in
some very distant cousins,
starting from the worm,
to the fly, to the mouse,
and maybe even to us.
[LAUGHTER]
We really don't
know about that yet.
But there are ongoing studies
that are quite interesting.
So if you think about this
and what does that mean,
it's very important in
terms of our frame of mind.
How do we think about aging?
And what are those
theories of aging?
You have heard probably
many theories of aging.
I know that there's more than
30 theories of aging, which
means that we don't
have any idea what we're
talking about or close to it.
Now, it's not
really entirely true
that we don't know what
we're talking about.
But it is true that there's
many theories of aging.
And in order to assess
them and to understand
which might be wrong
and which might
be right or partially
right, you need
to know what each theory
of aging needs to answer.
And one question like that
is why do organisms get less
resilient as they get older?
And the question that
I've already asked you,
why some members of one species
take about 70 years to complete
that process, whereas others
from a related species
take only two or three?
And yet another one is, why do
all tissues and cells kind of
start to decline
around the same time?
Why do they start to age
And finally, why is it that
these unifying interventions
and gene mutations are all
being able to affect aging
in very different animals?
So let's talk about some
of the theories of aging
that you must have heard.
I'm going to really
avoid about 25% of them
and talk maybe
about three or four.
You've heard about the oxidative
stress theory of aging.
And that one basically says
that if you have too much
unregulated oxygen in
your cells or tissues,
that oxygen will start binding
to your molecules at random.
It will disable.
Then they won't be able
to function as well.
A similar theory
about glycation.
You have too many sugars that
are important in the cell.
They're not regulated
properly metabolically.
They can glycate
other molecules.
And again, those molecules
will not function very well.
Well, there is
another one that was
formulated in the '60s by this
guy called Leonard Hayflick.
And Hayflick discovered that
if he put some human cells
in the tissue culture, that
they will divide 30, 40, 50
times and then they would stop.
And they will not
divide anymore.
And so that is
when he postulated
that this is just the exhaustion
of the dividing cells.
They just can't
divide any further.
And that theory got
another alternative
when the telomeres
were discovered.
And you've heard
about the telomeres.
These are those little ends
of the chromosomes that
ensure that the chromosomes
don't bind to one another
and cause cancer
and stuff like that.
And so the problem with the
telomeres is that every time
that the cell
divides, the telomere
gets shortened by a little bit.
And so you can imagine that if
you keep dividing and dividing,
you're going to exhaust your
telomeres, at which point
the cell is either going to die
or is going to sort of, like,
freeze and become an old cell.
And that is what
that theory says.
That because of your
short telomeres,
you actually end up
with senescent cells.
So let's examine that
particular theory.
We could examine any of
them along the lines.
So this one says that
shorter telomeres
will make cells stop growing.
And they will become senescent.
And they will
accumulate in your body.
And when you get to
chock-full of these old cells,
you will be old.
Pretty simple.
So one problem is that
we have some cells that
divide like crazy.
And they don't seem to
run out of telomeres.
So stem cells in our gut, that
renew the lining of our guts,
can divide in a mouse more
times than a mouse can live.
So that's obviously
not a limiting factor.
There's another problem that
most short-lived animals,
in fact, have very
long telomeres.
Mice have about three times
longer telomeres than we do.
So that kind of, like,
tells you something
is wrong with that picture.
Well, so the other problem is
that cells that don't divide,
such as our neurons, also age.
And it's obvious you don't need
to divide in order to grow old.
So what's going on there?
And finally, if you really
were to fill up with old cells,
you should be able to measure
that sort of, like, filling up.
It's sort of like the
gas tank and the pump.
And if you're getting
too many of them,
you're going to have to stop.
And our efforts to
identify those old cells
have been really not successful.
We haven't been able
to mark the cells
and say, well,
obviously this person
has many more old
cells than that person
and therefore he
or she is older.
So this is actually really
an interesting theory.
Telomeres are very
important in biology.
They're critically
important for cancer.
They're probably really not
important for aging at all.
Just an idea how
something that's popular,
and that you will find
all over the press,
is really not quite making
sense and not quite cutting
the mustard for
what we're looking
for when we talk about
the unifying problems
and issues of aging.
Well, we've made some progress.
And there is one theory
that makes more sense
than the others.
And it's centered around
metabolism and stress
in particular.
And it's reasonably simple.
It says that at some point,
nutrients and energy are not
being sensed the way
that they should be.
And we think that we have
plenty of everything.
And we don't think
to recycle ourselves.
And, therefore,
we kind of, like,
do the wrong things
with this energy.
And so when you
take that further,
it basically says
that this disbalance
leads to reduced resistance
to different forms of stress
or damage.
And so to simplify
that further, it's
basically paraphrased by saying
that if you or your cells
can deal with damage,
you will age well.
You remember that
Shane Burgess told you
about this longitudinal
study, where
they looked at people
that lived long lives,
into their hundreds.
And the only thing
that correlated
with their long lives
was their ability
to set aside stress in a way.
To take the stress
and say, like,
I have lived through something
bad and I'm letting it go now.
And I don't care
about it anymore.
So in the same
way, you can think
about the cells being
able to say, OK,
so I've been hit with
this burst of oxygen.
I have been hit with
these toxic substances.
I have been able now
to neutralize them.
And I'm moving forward.
So if you can deal with
damage, you will age well.
This is really the prediction.
And the revolution
came really when
people started examining
long-lived animals,
whether they were
living longer because
of a nutritional intervention,
or whether they were naturally
living longer, or whether
they were genetic mutants.
And so here is a
good case of that.
So mutations that make
some worms long-lived also
make their cells resistant to
stress, make them hard to kill.
So you have in these open
circles, the resistance
of a normal organism to heat.
You can see here now that
mutant worms resist heat
for much longer.
They can withstand being
exposed to heat for longer.
Similarly, if you
expose them to UV rays,
they do the same thing.
If you expose them to heavy
metal, they do the same thing.
If you expose them to oxidative
stress, they do the same thing.
So that's looking
pretty cool so far.
Well, let's see
whether it checks out.
So there are mice that live
40% longer than other mice
because they have changes in how
they sense energy and glucose.
And, as a consequence, these
mice have flexible tendons,
and their arthritis
doesn't develop quickly,
and they have less
kidney disease,
fewer cataracts, less cancer,
maintain the mental capacity.
And again, their cells
are resistant to stress.
They're very difficult
to kill if you
pull them out and do an
experiment in a tissue culture
dish.
So that now starts
looking pretty cool,
because you can conclude that
long-lived worms, and flies,
and the mice, all are resistant
to different forms of stress.
And the reason why
they're resistant
is because their
cells are individually
resistant to different
forms of stress.
So that stress resistance
really might be the cause
of the successful aging.
And this connection goes
way back in evolution.
It's very conserved.
So this is the illustration.
So the pathways that
lead to this stress
resistance in the cell.
And so what we're
looking at here
is really the
surface of the cell.
This would be how the
cells know what's happening
on the outside of them.
They have receptors for
different growth factors,
different nutrients, different
hormones, and so forth.
So if you look across species,
all the way back to the worm,
and up to the human, insulin
receptor and insulin growth
factor receptor-- it's
the same molecule,
the same receptor--
are very conserved.
They exist in each
one of these species.
And not only that,
but if you mutate them
or if you make them
less active, you
will increase lifespan in
the worm, and in the fly,
and in the mouse.
It hasn't been done in
the human obviously,
for a variety of reasons.
But what's more important
is that the hard wiring
of these receptors all the
way down to the cell, the way
that they talk to the cell, to
tell the cell, look, it's time
for you to divide or no,
it's time to hunker down,
there's not enough
nutrients and you
need to do different things,
is fundamentally the same.
Because these building
blocks that you see here
are highly conserved.
And, not only that, but if you
take individual pieces here,
that are sort of like at
the same level of signaling
downstream, and you cut them
out, or you disable them,
or you attenuate them, you
also get increased cell stress
resistance, and increased
lifespan, and health span.
So the challenge for the biology
of aging really at this stage
is to work out the
pathways by which
these single genes, enzymes,
hormones, hormone receptors,
and simple interventions
radically improve
a complex process of aging.
So that's challenge number one.
Challenge number two,
which is no less important,
is to scientifically
determine and figure
this out in a conversation
with the society.
Can we do this in humans?
Is this safe enough?
Can we get the same
effects in humans?
Is it efficient enough?
And finally, and
no less important,
should we do this in humans?
Is this ethical?
Is this reasonable
socioeconomically, and so
forth?
All of the important
questions that
will be addressed, particularly
by the fifth and sixth speaker
in this series.
So they will be
telling you a lot more
about societal resources,
about natural resources,
about redistribution,
and what one needs to do.
And I am very confident
that if we the biologists
can come up with
interventions like these,
so can our fellow scientists
come up with ideas about how
to more efficiently
use the resources,
help to generate more resources,
and how to distribute them
more equitably.
And that is the
question, of course,
that will unify all of our
presentations down the line.
So let's think about
this a little bit
from the standpoint
of our society
and of individual human beings.
You have all seen
these pictures.
These are the
demographic projections.
They were accurate and
based on data until 2008
in this particular slide.
And then from that point
on, they were projections.
And they project
that the population
over 65, and in particular
the population over 85,
will tremendously go up over
the next only 35 to 40 years.
And so what this is saying
is that 65s and older
will go up at least two-fold.
And those that are 85 and
older will basically quintuple.
They will go up fivefold over
that same period of time.
And so that's, of
course, fine, and dandy,
and cool because
most people really
live quite nice, active,
independent lives,
with self-reported good
health and satisfaction
for a nice, good
long period of time.
The problem is when
they no longer do that,
what are we going to do?
So, again, there's this
whole issue of health span.
And so I have an
example of health span
that I would like to
share with you here.
And it comes directly
from my family.
So this is my father,
Zarko Nikolic,
who's sitting here in the
audience and who is now 88,
and his older sister,
Radmia, who's 91.
And I'm convinced
that the reason
that my dad has done
so much in his life
and has been so successful
is that he was really
very bad at retiring.
I'm also convinced that my mom
had something to do with it
because she couldn't
tolerate him at home anymore.
She kicked him out repeatedly.
So his trajectory here was
that he retired the first time
back in '82, after 28 years as
a doctor, 15 years as a division
head in the hospital.
Worked for World
Health Organization,
retired after
three years; worked
as a medical consultant in a
health club, retired again.
Came to the US, started working
as a post-doctoral fellow
at the Memorial
Sloan-Kettering Cancer Center.
Worked until 2008,
retired again author
he published his second book.
And, of course, it's not
over, which is wonderful.
[APPLAUSE]
So being busy is quite
important, and quite useful,
and quite good.
And unfortunately, some
people cannot be as busy
because the qualities of their
lives are not at that level.
And so our problem is
that we're spending
an increasingly enormous
amount trying to get
those people to be better.
And 10% of the sickest and
frailest Medicare patients
account for over 60% of our
total Medicare spending.
I don't think that these
figures are entirely new to you.
But these are staggering
numbers when you think about it.
What is much worse
than that is that they
don't receive great care.
And that I'm sure
you know about,
that there's 14 different
docs looking at everything
from your pinky, all
the way to your earlobe,
nobody talking to one another,
and everybody prescribing
their own drugs.
You're being admitted, released,
readmitted into the hospital,
and so forth.
So that's a problem.
And the additional
problem that we face here
is that if we continue with
this business as usual,
we really use this irreplaceable
source and resource of wisdom
and experience and energy.
So, in other words, what we want
would be something like this.
And what we get is this.
And this is, unfortunately,
an actual sign
from a street somewhere
in the United States
warning you that some elderly
people can run under your car.
[LAUGHTER]
So go figure.
So there's some immediate
help that's on the way.
And I'm proud to say
that our Center on Aging
is at the forefront of that
research and of the initiatives
to change this.
And these are really the
changes to how our health care
delivery works.
It's really now
incumbent upon us
to accept and to adopt
the team-based home care,
where there will be high
coordination between all
of these providers
that are really
in the service of the
person that they're
trying to help in their home.
There is this hugely
important concept
of telehealth and
telemonitoring,
where a person at home can
take not only blood pressure,
and heart rate, and simple
things, but certainly
glucose levels, blood sugar,
and advanced biometrics,
like whether this person may
be more prone towards falling
because the gate is unstable.
There's telemonitoring
along those lines.
And so Mindy Fain and
Jane Mohler in our center
are really national leaders
in this particular effort.
And I'm sure that it will
bear fruit very soon.
But even if this all
works wonderfully well,
we're still not going to
resolve all of our problems.
The economics are kind of
like against in this case.
And so really it's
the biology of aging
that will have to
step to the plate
and can step to the plate.
And again, it's this same curve.
We're trying to move from this
disability-free survival that
is now somewhat
constrained, all the way up,
by moving these lines
in the upper corner.
So what we're looking for
it to happen is wonderful.
But we unfortunately have
an elephant in the room.
So here there are two elephants.
And one of them is a
geriatric elephant.
And the elephant is ageism.
You have heard the word.
It is one of the
unaddressed isms
that we are currently
confronting.
So if we are building a world
and a health care system
where we can grow
old, then we shouldn't
be seeing a sign like this.
I mean this sign is implying
that these people don't know
what they're doing
really and they're
a danger to everybody else.
They are not a resource
clearly over here.
If you were to
extrapolate this, you
would get something like this.
[LAUGHTER]
So who's to tell you at what
point you should be put down?
It's a pretty interesting point.
Or something like this?
You came and you had
an expiration date
on your forehead, where
somebody would basically
say at this point,
you are irrelevant.
You're invisible.
You're no longer really
considered a productive part
of the society.
And so there are
several answers to that.
One of them would be this.
But the other really
is this-- sorry,
this-- that we really
need to treat older
adults as a societal resource.
And that is the change of
thinking that we need to adopt.
So in the end what
I would like to see
is the return of
this vast wisdom,
and experience, and
energy to the society.
Whether it's to the
family, which is wonderful
and which my children
have certainly
benefited from having my parents
around and growing with them.
Whether it's to the
community, or whether it's
to the society at large.
I think that this is really
an incredibly important point.
And I would just like to
digress a little of it
and wish my parents happy
56th anniversary today.
[APPLAUSE]
So we really want to
change the face of aging.
And we really want to harness
how these genes and diets are
working so that we can
change the face of aging.
So what can we really
do realistically?
Here's a few things that we
really cannot do and don't want
to do.
These things work.
But they work on
mice and on worms.
And they're really not
under consideration.
We're not going to be
genetically altering humans
before birth.
And we're not going to do
that to them after birth.
And caloric restriction,
if you think about it,
it would mean either chucking
away or clearly downsizing
your Big Mac.
And so in our society, that's
not very palatable either.
So that in its present form
will probably not work.
But it might work if we
can actually distill this
into specific a treatment
or a specific drug that
might be working on
the clear pathways
so as to produce these
positive effects.
So what we can do,
what we could achieve,
and if you realistically look at
what has been achieved so far--
I told you that caloric
restriction increases lifespan
by about 30% to 40%,
to 45% sometimes;
other interventions
between 30% and 60%.
So let's say that 40%
would be realistically
achievable, defensible
scientifically certainly.
At that point,
really the equivalent
of the human lifespan, the
mean, would be 112 years.
And these are the 111
that would be healthy.
And then with that,
we now achieve
the title of this series
and we can all go home.
Well, can't we do
something else?
Can't we just take care
of all of the diseases?
So these are the nine main
causes of death in the US.
And let's examine what
they mean individually.
So an average female
that's roughly around 50
in the US today would be
expected to live to about 81.
Well, let's say
that we cure cancer.
If we cure cancer, that person
would gain roughly about three
to four years of lifespan.
If we did the same
with heart disease,
pretty much about the same.
Let's cure cancer
and heart disease.
You'd get about
six to seven years.
Nice.
You get cancer, heart
disease, stroke, and diabetes,
and you get about roughly
13 to 15 years of lifespan.
But really the promise
of delaying aging
is something that is
much more substantial.
And the nice thing
about it is that it
takes care along the way of
all of these other issues.
And that is really
what's at stake.
what we're looking at.
So if this is what
we want to do,
why is it that we
didn't do it before?
So the first problem
is that aging
is viewed very incorrectly, as
I hope I have convinced you,
as an unalterable process.
It really isn't.
We can do a lot about it.
The second one is that
if you have somebody
who comes out and tells you
I'm going to delay aging,
or I'm going to
slow aging, or I'm
going to do
something with aging,
very often they will
come with a wacko idea.
And even if it's
not a wacko idea,
it would be like, oh,
I'm not sure about this.
This guy might be a nut case.
If you look at the profits,
you can realize a lot of profit
from alleged
anti-aging medications.
There are tons of products
out there that don't work.
But they turn
millions in profits.
You have seen them
all over the place.
Sorry.
This is actually supposed
to be gradually coming up.
But in the end I think the
crowding works just as well.
There are all of the
fountain of youths,
all of the how to live forever
extracts, and so forth.
Please don't buy them.
Well, the other issues
here are, well, it's
not that easy to really find age
changing medications, or drugs,
or treatments that would be
safe and effective for humans.
But I would like to argue that
the reason why this hasn't been
easy is that we really have
not invested sufficiently
or not nearly sufficiently
into that field.
It's really the lack of
funding that is the biggest
obstacle in this case.
And to back that
up, I would like
you to consider what are
the funds allocated for that
in the United States
annually through
the federal organizations
that sponsor research.
So the biggest federal sponsor
of this type of research
are the National
Institutes of Health.
And they dole out to
us, the scientists
around the country,
roughly a huge budget that
gets distributed here, of which
the National Institute on Aging
gets a mere 3.3%.
That's not very good.
Well, when you really
examine the situation
and you look at
what's underneath,
and the biology of aging
program is only one
of the programs of the NIH,
it really gets only 0.5.%.
And what is really
dismal is the next one.
I don't know how many of you
can see this dot over here.
It is 200th of 1% of the
total budget for research.
And so it's really
impossible to move forward
with that level of funding.
So the conclusion
here is pretty simple.
Our investment into poor health
care for older adults is huge.
Our investment into
changing the face of aging
is really ridiculously small.
And so we're very good as
a society at curing crisis,
reacting to crisis,
a monster disease.
We're lousy at
preventing things.
We really don't like
to think forward.
So when we think
about making sure
that the disease doesn't
occur in the first place
and that we're healthy
as we go along,
there is just not enough
of a motivator for us
for some reason to
say this is the goal
and this is what we
need to go forward with.
So can we change?
Obviously, this is neither
smart nor economical.
But the real question
is can we change?
So I would like
to do another quiz
and get your show of hands.
I'm going to make you
guys the underwriters
of the federal budget.
You hold the purse strings.
You're writing a check.
And if I came to you or anybody
came to you with this point
here, we have an
experimental treatment
that diminishes by 90% the risk
of breast cancer in aged rats.
How many of you would think
that this is a good thing
to support, to
give more money to?
I need a show of hands.
Thank you.
Well, if I told you then
that this same treatment has
some side effects and
they're all fantastic.
The side effects here are
that you don't get cataracts,
and you don't get cancer, and
you don't decline cognitively,
there's no immune failure,
there's no kidney disease,
how many of you would
support it then?
Cool.
And how about if I told you also
that it leads in animal models
to about a tenfold increase
of lifespan over that which
would be predicted only by
curing cancer, how many would
support it then?
Can you all please register
and go run for Congress?
I really need you there.
You are much better than our
politicians in this case.
Well, this is the
final conclusion here.
We've looked at the
situation and we're
confronted with
insurmountable opportunities.
We've met the enemy
and the enemy is us.
OK.
So a couple of more pieces
of data before we conclude.
Another treatment that really
captured the imagination
of the scientific community.
This is a drug that
has been approved
in the US for many, many decades
as a drug against transplant
rejection.
It's called rapamycin.
And some people, based
on their research,
thought that it would be a good
idea to give rapamycin to mice.
And not only that, but they
gave this treatment to mice
when the mice were already
2/3 done with their lifespan.
So these are the
mice that really have
only the last third to live.
And miraculously,
rapamycin, in the mice
that are shown here in red,
that were given the drug,
it made them live longer
than the mice that
were in blue, that were getting
the regular diet and no drug
at all.
So rapamycin does
something pretty amazing.
It can extend
lifespan, even when
you start taking it when you're
about 60 or so in human years.
So what to do next here?
There are a lot of questions
coming up with this thing.
So a lot of interest.
What is the best
dose of rapamycin?
Does it work on dogs or monkeys?
How are people in
rapamycin trials doing?
Some people get it
also for cancer.
Again, this is the question
of whether that dose will
be good for aging or not?
Are some of the targets of
rapamycin good and some bad?
Do you get real health span
extension with rapamycin?
Are there other drugs
like rapamycin that
might be safer, more efficient?
Does this one produce serious
side effects at the doses
when it extends the lifespan?
All of the questions that
we need to figure out.
And so the last three here
that you see in orange
are part of the
project in which we're
working at the Center on
Aging, with collaboration
of our colleagues from
colleges of medicine,
and agriculture,
and life sciences.
And so many of these
team members are here.
I'd like to acknowledge them.
Ted Price, and Gersten Lemison,
and Hedron Brooks, Sirab Gosh,
and Emily Goldberg are here.
The other project that we're
working on deals with vaccines.
Infectious diseases
are really no longer
a problem for children
and they're no longer
a problem for adults,
at least in our society.
They are still a problem
for older adults.
And it is appalling
to know and understand
that there is no single vaccine
that has ever been engineered
or formulated specifically
to be good for older adults
because their immune systems are
very specific and have problems
that the other immune
systems do not.
And so we're working on these
problems very specifically.
My lab is working on this.
And we have some very
interesting and promising leads
about trying to formulate
new vaccines as we go along.
We also work on
immune rejuvenation.
There are organs that
generate the blood cells.
And in particular there is
a gland called the thymus.
And it's very young, and plump,
and juicy when we're young.
This is how it looks.
But in the old age,
it really shrinks
to this almost invisible
tiny little mass.
The good news is that this mass
can now be regrown and turned
into something like this,
even in an old mouse.
And we're now studying
how this works
and does it give you better
immunity, as it's supposed to?
So with all of
this, I would like
to give my final conclusion.
And the final conclusion is
this is where we stand today.
[LAUGHTER]
For all the mice
in the audience,
I have wonderful news.
But unfortunately, I can't
say that for the people.
And the long and the short
of it and the final message
of the talk here is
please get involved.
We need you.
We need you as the
friends of the center
and the friends
of the university.
And we need you
as our advocates.
Thank you very
much for listening.
I'd be glad to
answer any questions.
[APPLAUSE]
Are there any questions?
And you started with the mice.
Did you find any
gender-based differences?
For example, my relatives live--
the female lives into the teens
sometimes.
The males do not.
So in those set of
mice, the gender factor?
So the gender factor exists.
But it's not the one
that's going to abrogate
what I told you about.
Caloric restriction,
and these mutants,
and rapamycin that
I have shown you,
all extend lifespan
in both sexes.
Are the people who are setting
the budgets for research
in the National Institutes
of Health politicians
or scientists?
Politicians.
Sometimes they call
us to talk to them.
And they sometimes
pretend to listen.
Last session and
now this, you're
talking about severely
reducing-- well, not severely,
but reducing caloric intake.
So you have the quote, unquote,
"standard 2,000 calories a day
diet."
So is it realistic that the
standard calorie diet should be
in the 1,400 or
1,500 calorie a day?
People that are currently
parts of the human studies--
and there are human
studies happening currently
in the three centers.
One is at Washington University
at St. Louis, one is at Tufts,
and one is at the Pennington
Institute in Louisiana
at LSU-- are all
taking approximately
the amount of calories
that you're talking about.
I really don't think-- so that's
sort of like the factual answer
to your question.
What's realistic in terms
of the general public?
I thought that I made it
fairly clear that I don't view
calorie restriction
in its current form
as a realistic treatment, as a
broadly administered treatment.
Our goal really is to
understand how it works and then
potentially find mimetics
of caloric restrictions
that are going to mimic it
and do the same thing, drugs
that act along the pathway
to do the same trick.
Yes?
Care to guess how
rapamycin might work?
Well, so there is a pathway.
There is a signaling
pathway that
rapamycin very
directly hits, that
is exactly along
these same lines
that I have been talking about.
It really senses whether you
have enough nutrients or not.
And so it's measuring how
much amino acids there
are on the outside, how much
glucose there is on the inside.
It intersects with
the insulin pathway.
And at that point it
decides, is the cell
supposed to go into sort of like
this Conan the Barbarian phase?
I can do everything.
I'm strong.
I can divide.
I can go into hypertrophy.
Or whether it's going to go
into the phase, oh, my god,
there isn't anything
on the outside.
I've got to hunker down.
The good thing
about hunkering down
in that situation--
and this is probably
the basis of both rapamycin,
and caloric restriction,
and a number of
other things-- is
that the cell then kind of
recycles itself to some extent.
And it only devotes its
energy to the most essential
processes.
And in the process,
it gets younger
because it chomps up a
little bit of itself.
It kind of like, there is a
process called autophagy, which
really in English would
mean, self-eating.
I'm eating a little bit of
myself in order to recycle it.
And that is the best guess
that I can give you right now.
It's a fairly educated guess,
probably likely to be true.
What advances are being
made in Alzheimer's?
So I didn't get that.
What advances are being
made with Alzheimer's?
To my knowledge, nothing.
Well, all of these interventions
actually significantly
delay and reduce the onset of
Alzheimer's as well, at least
in the animal model.
So you could argue
that the mice never
developed quite the
Alzheimer's that the people do.
But inasmuch as they
have looked in the animal
models that can be generated,
they do the same thing.
Now in terms of the therapy
and the current advances
against the Alzheimer's
disease by itself,
I would like to
deflect that question
and leave it for
Carole Barnes, who's
going to be talking
about the brain
aging in the next session.
She will be much more
qualified to talk about it.
This is kind of a continuation
of the discussion of reduced
caloric intake.
If you reduce your
caloric intake
so that you are meeting
this 40%-- or 33% less
and you also increase
your antioxidant input,
does this address the
oxidative stress you refer to?
I have referred to the
oxidative stress mostly
to illustrate that there is a
theory about aging that talks
about oxidative stress.
The oxidative stress theory of
aging is far from being proven.
There were many clinical
trials that we're trying.
One of the gold
criteria for that
would be like, if you put
people on antioxidants,
would they live longer?
And the answer has
never been a yes so far.
If you don't take
enough antioxidants
through your regular
food, you might be
needing to take antioxidants.
And antioxidants in
certain very carefully
controlled medical conditions
may be a important part
of the therapy.
They are likely not the
anti-aging medication
because the point with
oxidation and oxidative
stress inside the cell is
that oxidative metabolites are
very important parts of
normal cellular signaling.
So when the cell
is alive and well,
and when it does what
it's supposed to do,
a cross-talk inside
the cell happens
by having these oxidative
products be produced and moved
from one place in the
cell to the other.
If you completely
inhibit that, you
can imagine that you
will be interfering
with something else.
That's really not likely to
improve your health span.
So I think that those are
two quite distinct things.
Again, we have been told that
you need to have antioxidants
over, and over, and over.
And really putting that in
the situation if somebody
has a certain
disease, if somebody
has a deficiency of
certain vitamins,
then you definitely
need to take them.
But it's very questionable as
to whether a healthy person
absorbing enough normal
nutrients from regular food,
particularly fresh
fruits and vegetables,
really needs a
whole lot of that.
Now, if there is a
problem with absorption
that might then
come back into play.
But I really would
hesitate to say
that that's a universal thing
that every should be doing.
Some while ago I read a book
called Younger Next Year.
It talks a lot about exercise
and its effect on aging.
It talked about how exercise can
bring on different enzymes that
help rebuild tissue.
I noticed you barely, if at
all, even mentioned exercise.
Is it not a part of the
field of research of aging
or is it just not
something that you--
No.
It's an important
part of the field.
I think the reason
why I didn't mention
it is that we really
didn't have exactly 16
hours for the lecture.
But exercise is critically
important for the well-being.
And it's critically
important for the well-being
of not only the
body as we grow old,
but for the mind even more.
It's probably more important to
do physical exercise in terms
of the well-being of your mind
than to do the Sudoku exercise.
I wouldn't say that you
shouldn't do the other one.
But definitely, the first
one you must be doing.
There are comparative
studies that
were done comparing exercise,
so moderate exercise,
heavy exercise, sort of
like Olympic level training,
for instance, and caloric
restriction in terms
of what they do biochemically.
And in animal studies, as well
as in human studies, the long
and the short comes
to it that there
is a huge beneficial effect
for the quality of life.
Exercise has never been
able to extend longevity
in any of the models.
So it will probably
make you healthier.
It will probably not
make you live longer.
So if that is your thing,
that's-- But certainly I would
say that exercise should be part
of everybody's lives as they
grow older, and as
they grow younger.
It's my understanding that
certain nutrients, for example,
resveratrol, which
is found in red wine
and so on and accounts for the
fact that the French live so
long, in spite of the fact
that they eat, I think,
56 pounds of butter per
person per year, etc.
What do you think of
those things that mimic
caloric restriction, nutrients?
So resveratrol was
a huge thing when
the molecule-cultured
twins were discovered.
And so twins are probably
very important in wiring
the cellular signaling.
And the problem with
resveratrol was in as much
as it was potentially an
attractive pharmacological
substance, it has never
been able to extend lifespan
or health span in any
of the studies so far.
It has only been able to
do some good to obese mice.
So if you have a
highly abnormal diet,
there could be maybe some value
of taking some of the mimetics.
I would certainly not advise
you against having any red wine.
I think that's probably
a very good thing to do.
But resveratrol is probably
not an anti-aging medication.
And here's the last question.
So it better be a good one.
[LAUGHTER]
No pressure.
Yeah.
No pressure in this one at all.
I'm just wondering, are people
working on immortalized cell
lines, the HeLa cells and others
that have genetic defects?
Or cancer cell lines
and abnormal cell lines,
but they are immortalized?
Are those used as
tools to uncover this?
Not that much in aging research.
Because by definition,
these cells
have growth factor
abnormalities.
They have basic mechanisms
that are supposed to keep them
in place, profoundly altered.
And so what they can
tell you about aging
is not all that informative.
They can probably tell you
a lot about, for instance,
things like DNA repair, or
regulation of the cell cycle,
or how the cells divide.
Certainly, a lot to
tell you about cancer.
But not really about
the process of aging.
Well, let us thank Janko
for a great lecture.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]